Hollywood can never be totally sure what audiences
will like, and with every mega-hit and critical
darling, there come a few more shows doomed
to a quick cancellation.
According to the critics, these are the worst
shows to hit broadcast TV, cable, and streaming
services in 2019.
Network TV's biggest breakout hit over the
last three years or so is unquestionably This
Is Us, NBC's sprawling, time-jumping, touching
family tearjerker.
As that formula has proven successful, other
similar shows have hit the airwaves, including
NBC's own The Village.
Rather than focus on a family, it's an attempt
at a poignant, heartwarming and emotionally
devastating show about the diverse residents
of a Brooklyn apartment building.
It's about how everyone's lives interact in
ways both subtle and profound, and feels specifically
designed to get audiences to cry.
Dustin Rowles of Pajiba says:
"The Village has no interest in being a decent
series; its only interest is in using emotional
manipulation to gaslight its viewers into
believing that The Village is trying to say
something profound about the human condition."
More than 15 years after the release of Bad
Boys II, the franchise returned to life with
a made-for-TV spinoff starring Gabrielle Union
and Jessica Alba.
They play an LAPD detective team who are,
get this, very different, personality-wise.
In short, L.A.'s Finest embraces a formula
that's been used countless times before in
movies and TV.
Critics were savage, finding the end results
ordinary, outdated, and unnecessary.
Ben Travers of IndieWire criticized the standard
storytelling in his review:
"Everyone can find another show exactly like
this one on Fox or other broadcast networks,
USA or other cable outlets, and even streaming
services."
"Don't make me shoot you!
Because I'm not missing family book club."
After American Idol became a top-rated pop
culture juggernaut in the early 2000s, talent
shows flooded TV.
In 2019, CBS used its valuable post-Super
Bowl programming slot to launch yet another
entry in the genre: The World's Best.
In some ways, the James Corden-hosted show
is formulaic and familiar.
Like The Voice and American Idol, performers
compete in front of a panel of celebrities.
And like America's Got Talent, acts of every
stripe are welcome, not just singers.
But in its attempt to flip the script and
get innovative, The World's Best goes too
far and just winds up overly complicated.
In addition to doing their thing for the judges,
performers are rated by up to 50 experts from
38 geographic regions, purporting to be experts
in different forms of entertainment.
Then, all the various musicians, comedians,
karate masters, etc. compete against each
other for the title of "The World's Best"
overall new talent.
Caroline Framke, writing at Variety wrote:
"So very much of the show boils down to the
show explaining itself and stretching out
the 'judging,' which mostly just consists
of the panelists gushing and gasping in awe."
What if Netflix made a TV show that played
like a cheesy '90s-style erotic thriller?
And what if they got an Academy Award-winning
actress to star in it?
The answer to questions is What / If, a steamy
primetime soap from Netflix about a high-powered
and glamorous Silicon Valley investor played
by Renée Zellweger.
In between her time spent screaming her frustrations
into a stuffed animal and practicing archery
on human targets, she helps out Lisa, an idealistic
young head of a biotech company in exchange
for a night with the woman's husband, Sean.
The whole thing is such an inscrutable mess
that David Opie of Digital Spy wrote:
"There's a strong chance that the team behind
What / If know exactly what they're doing,
deliberately setting out to make something
that's intrinsically 'bad.'"
Katee Sackhoff, the breakout star of the classic
2000s reboot of Battlestar Galactica makes
her triumphant return to sci-fi television
with Another Life, a tense Netflix drama about
a spaceship full of humans on its way to make
first contact with aliens.
Unfortunately for Galactica fans, Another
Life is not quite the worthy follow-up they
wanted.
This ambitious show is part workplace drama,
as starship commander Niko Breckenridge looks
after a craft headed to a far-away alien planet
which sent a giant, creepy crystal to Earth.
Giving her plenty of guff is her number-two,
Ian, the now-demoted former captain of that
very ship.
Awkward.
Meanwhile, her husband back on Earth is the
only man who can crack the code of the giant
creepy crystal.
There's a lot going on with Another Life,
but according to Alex McLevy of The AV Club,
it doesn't all work:
"Another Life is an unwieldy mashup of Arrival
and any number of space-odyssey adventure
serials, and struggles to maintain clarity
or depth with either half of its bifurcated
storyline.
While this CW summer science-fiction series
shares a name with another famous science-fiction
property, Pandora actually takes place primarily
on Earth.
Nevertheless, it cribs heavily from plenty
of other popular sci-fi.
Pandora is a Star Trek-esque series set at
the space travel training ground of Starfleet
Academy in everything but name.
It begins in 2199 on a Tatooine-like space
world called New Portland, where a college-age
woman named Jax is the only survivor of a
devastating attack.
So, she's shipped off to Fleet Training Academy
on Earth, where she'll study under the tutelage
of her uncle alongside a number of familiar
sci-fi character archetypes.
All the while, Jax may have a special secret
which may affect the very future of humankind.
Lightweight and exceedingly familiar can be
fine, especially for a summer TV show.
But Pandora doesn't quite strike that tone.
Beth Elderkin of io9 was exceedingly harsh
in her review:
"I watch a lot of TV pilots for work, including
ones for shows that never make it to air,
and Pandora's is quite possibly one of the
worst I've seen in years."
"I'm not sure we're completely getting off
on the right foot here, are we?"
"Well, it appears I'm not the only one that's
perceptive then."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.